Dave Chappelle is recording a brand new
standup special and gave Shane Gillis
the honor of opening the show which
turned out to be a pretty difficult task
I was with Chappelle all week not big
deal but then uh not big deal just had
to tell you guys where I was whatever
dude because it's a taping they have to
start on time so they're like all right
7 get the [__] out there dude I go out
to 30% full all black
room lights on no one's in their seats
people are just the whole time people
are just walking in everyone's I [__]
every single show I [__] Hae it like
you wouldn't believe and I just had to
stand there like hey what's up guys
people were
just many comedy fans thought Chappelle
was done recording specials for a while
after he named his last Netflix hour the
closer but new information has revealed
that